Hi there, Steve Kauffmann here.
Today we have a special
guest, Alberto Salas, of Mr Salas.
Which is his presence
on the internet.
And Alberto, I´m gonna
let you introduce yourself
but I briefly sort of
introduce our discussion
to say that I wanna
cover some of the ground
that I´ve covered
in my recent videos.
And then maybe
go over in spanish,
for the benefit of people
who are learning spanish
or for spanish speakers
who would like to hear
some of this material
discussed in spanish.
But first, Alberto, could you
please introduce yourself?
Alberto: Yes, of course.
Hello there, Mr. Salas here.
So I´m a Mexican YouTuber.
I tend to like upload stuff
about learning languages,
using comprehensible
input, learning on your own,
you know, overall, just
how to optimize your time
and your money,
in order to learn languages.
So that´s kind of my gag.
We could say.
Steve: Allright, that
is a very good leading,
to what I´d like to
discuss with you,
first in english and
then in spanish.
And that is, like my last 3 videos
touchdown is kind of related issues.
First of all I said
"Don´t learn the basics".
And of course, people should
go there and watch that video,
but the idea is that we
learn things according to
an order which really isn´t
gonna change very much,
regardless of how much
instruction or specific attention
we place on certain basics.
It´ll gradually come to
us, if we continue doing
our listening and reading.
And then I said, you know,
Rather than focusing
on the long term goal
"I wanna be fluent", focus
on developing good habits,
and I made reference
to atomic habits.
And the third
one, I talked about
the different
stages of enjoyment.
Again, the focus is on
enjoying the language,
rather than sort of rigid
instruction, such as we're used to.
And so those three videos,
I think you said you looked
at, at least one of them.
Alberto: Yeah.
Steve: I think it's very
close to your message.
And, you know, how we
can encourage people to
maybe get out from
under the legacy
of formal instruction
in our school system.
And I say that without knowing
what the situation is in Mexico,
how languages are taught
in Mexico, and so forth.
Maybe you could give us your
sort of take on these videos.
And the state of language
instruction, in Mexico and elsewhere.
Alberto: Sure, like, uh, actually,
I think I don't have a lot
of teacher fans in Mexico.
Because usually I tend
to be a little, you know,
I wouldn't say rude.
I'm just like more of a
"Oh, this is actually not
very good for learning."
"Oh, this thing we
do is not really good."
But I do think it's not the teachers
fault, but rather the system.
You know, like, we tried to
make students pass exams,
not learn languages.
And I mean, actually,
That was the same situation
in Japan, by the way, right?
So it's really similar.
It's actually uncanny, how
similar like the way they learn this.
Steve: But it's not unique
to either Mexico or Japan.
Because in Canada, kids
in the English school system,
unless they're in French immersion,
if they're learning French as a subject,
they don't learn very much,
because it's the same emphasis
on passing tests.
Interesting point, you speak
a number of languages.
But recently, you have
been learning Japanese,
and then you went to Japan.
Tell us a little bit
of your background.
How, when did you
get into Japanese?
And what was your experience
when you were in Japan?
Alberto: Well, I'm
preparing a video about that.
So hopefully, I'll get
that soon enough,
because I've been failing
at Japanese for about,
I would like to say 10
years, but that's not realistic.
Because I tried to learn when
I was like, at the university.
But I mean, I didn't
really get into it, right.
But I got much more into it
like 2 years ago,
when my channel started.
I tried to learn using some of
the things I thought could work.
And funnily enough, like,
the things that worked for me
for German or English,
didn't actually work for Japanese,
which was interesting.
So I had to, like
change it a little.
I had never had to learn
a language that required
to be able to read
something first.
Before actually immersing
or whatever, right.
I had had situations like in
German what I had to learn,
the phonetics of
the language when,
two or three vowels are together
and the way they sound shorten,
but that's not the same thing as
learning the syllables in Japanese.
Or even worse, the kanji.
So, yeah, it was a
very, very recent thing.
Steve: It's interesting.
It's interesting.
Of course, I think we both agree,
at least certainly, in my view,
reading is such a powerful
way to improve in a language
and an important goal
in learning a language.
When you're dealing with
the different writing system
then you have you
know, it's a major obstacle.
And we never quite
get as comfortable
in a different writing
system as we are in our own.
So as a Spanish speaker,
you're learning English
or learning German,
you're learning Italian,
it's the same writing system.
So it's a lot easier
from that point of view
to get right into it.
But I think regardless of the
obstacles and the difficulties,
I still believe we have
to enjoy the language
or we aren't going to succeed.
Maybe we can now speak
a little bit of spanish.
Alberto: Yes, of course.
Steve: You have to do it with pleasure
and enjoy the language learning process.
Cause if we focus on grammar,
and the basic rules of language
as an obligation,
because we have exams,
making linguistic growth is very challenging.
00:06:00,733 --> 00:06:02,033
What do you think?
Alberto: I think it's frustrating
for many people more than just difficult.
00:06:10,533 --> 00:06:13,167
Because about a language,
and this is what I always tell people,
Learning a language is not difficult;
rather, it is challenging.
And I'm referring to complicated
because it's not like that
I'll be learning English in classes for six months.
No. It heavily incorporates
the teacher's methodology
or the materials they are using.
Or, as you say, Steve,
how much you like it.
Because it's very easy to give up something
you don't like after a month.
And I frequently use the same analogy
when referring to the gym.
To me, learning a language and exercising
are almost identical.
It requires having a lot of willpower
to do it continuously day after day.
In my opinion, doing it yourself
through self-learning works best.
at your own pace,
doing the things you enjoy.
That is the problem with the school,
they believe the content you are
consuming right now is better.
The audios and role plays you do,
are those that the school consider the best.
And frequently it's not the best environment
for your specific learning.
I understand that it must be universal,
in order to function for everyone as a whole.
And that´s why I think that is the major flaw
in the instruction at the schools.
An Instructor that lead you by the hand.
It's possible that you aren't interested
in what you're learning.
And as you say, that is the most essential thing.
to learn a language.
That you are interested in it and enjoy it,
as you correctly stated.
Steve: There is an order,
according to Steven Krashen's theory.
In learning language structures, words,
or other linguistic facets.
There is no inherent order.
Whatever the professor may teach
about the subjunctive and other concepts,
the English "tenses."
But you will learn those things according to this order.
No need to worry.
And as a consequence, exams and texts
make you anxious about test results in particular.
And refrain from letting any language
enter your head.
Therefore, you must believe
in this innate learning process.
I believe that the way that
language is taught in schools,
destroys this sense of independence.
Everything is according to the teacher's words.
"You're going to read this content."
" Now that I have taught you this,
let's see if you have understood
what I have taught you."
But ultimately,
the head cannot function in this way.
The way that is taught in schools
is therefore against nature.
And above all, because the learner
lacks this independence,
which is crucial in language learning.
Alberto: Yes, and I believe that many people
believe this when they hear, for instance,
that I learned Alemán by watching Netflix.
And then I did a little shadowing practice.
What I learned the most from was playing
computer games and watching Netflix.
Many people take that to be true, especially in Mexico,
because this is my own unique experience.
People frequently say,
"You're lying to me,"
You're trying to tell me this..."
Unquestionably, there is a strong opposition to
the notion of learning naturally, as you claim.
And I think my hypothesis for why this continues
to be the case today is that,
despite all the content that is already available,
90% of people find it to be ineffective,
For stating a number, right?
Because I believe it works better
for those who are more logical.
Like when they say, "A, B, C, D, perfect."
And they are building it as well.
But they are a minority.
I believe that in order to learn in this way
you must be a genius.
That is my belief.
It's my opinion.
I believe that the vast majority of us learn naturally.
Simply filling us to the brim.
And that is what I tell the students,
"Speak to the language, wherever it may be.
No matter"
No initial step exists.
Because that "I know basic English" stuff…
"I'll start with the basics and work my way up,"
seems unusual to me.
And I think that stems from the notion of how
text-based library structures.
They start off by using the simple present.
Then, the present continuous comes after
the simple present.
After the present continuous, simple past, and so on.
This leads to the delusion
that the present perfect
is an advanced topic while
the simple present is a basic topic..
When that isn't true.
Simply put, there are various contexts
in which the language is used.
But I think that's the reason.
For a teacher, I think it's easier
to prepare a lesson plan
and set up a schedule.
I'm talking about a school curriculum.
If it is based on skills like pieces
or linguistic chunks,
a class of understandable information,
or a class of habits.
That is very ambiguous.
I believe it to be difficult.
In fact, I'd like to know, Steve,
what you think about
how this contribution could be made in a classroom.
Steve: Yes, this is very difficult,
but we must acknowledge
that the world has changed.
And as you say, there are plenty
of online contents now, like Netflix.
And other things, so we don't need
the teacher to explain the entire lesson to us..
We must learn, byy using this content
as a starting point,
Content is available everywhere.
We can choose and look for interesting things.
And perhaps students can study
different subjects in one class.
Three alumni: alumni A, B, and C.
They will be studying through various contents.
Then they can discuss about
the material they studied..
But there is also the matter of the book
I mentioned in the film, "Atomic Habits."
Hábitos atómicos.
Habits and activities must be developed
on one's own.
It's crucial that you engage in
enjoyable learning activities
every day or nearly every day.
And that you have habits for doing things,
listening to or reading, or speaking.
Every day, every day, every day.
This is more significant than any exam.
Because of this, we at LingQ
measure activity levels
rather than level, which is difficult.
And if someone has good habits
and is involved with the language every day,
they will advance.
Without making reference to any book or test.
Alberto: Well, LingQ, it seems to be
more based on reading, right?
00:14:09,867 --> 00:14:12,600
Steve: No, no, because everything is...
I started out by listening.
And while listening, 20% to 30%
of what I hear is unclear.
And after that, I'm going to read
and save phrases and words.
to study those words and phrases.
There are many functions that help me understand
words and phrases.
But I always start with listening.
I spend more time hearing than reading.
But it's all part of the input, so.
Alberto: I think a lot of people have said to me,
"Okay, but how do you start?"
How do you start,
if you are a total beginner in a language?
How exactly can you begin learning that language?
Because, for instance, you say that you don't
understand 20% or 30% of the words.
However, if you're starting from scratch,
I doubt you'll understand anything.
Or one or two that you heard
at your best at some point.
How does Steve Kaufmann start
learning a language from scratch?
Because I don't think you start out
understanding the 20% or the 30%,
that's cheating.
You then understand the language.
How does that work?
Steve: I started out by listening
to short stories.
I won't understand anything,
but it will make sense to me.
Then I'll read a phrase at a time,
look up words, read it again,
and listen to it again.
And finally, I'm going to hear
the three-minute mini-story.
I won't understand much of it,
so I'll read it again.
And eventually after that, I'll be bored,
so I'll put myself in the position
to study the next short story.
And I won't understand much.
00:16:07,467 --> 00:16:10,567
But eventually I'll have heard it 20 times.
And after 20 times of hearing,
five times of reading,
and saving phrases and words,
the noise will gradually
begin to make sense.
This process, which I've used numerous times,
is effective.
Since there is so much repetition
in the short stories,
this works.
Numerous beginner's books fall short
of having enough repetitions.
When we first start, we'll have
to run into those words a lot.
a lot, a lot of times.
The same words, the same vocabulary,
and the same story
all appear four or five times in one story.
And so, after three months,
I can gradually start looking for more interesting
YouTube content or whatever.
Alberto: Contenido real, ¿no?
Steve: Yes, real.
However, we can continue talking for hours on end
and will continue on your channel.
Alberto: Exactly.
I invite you to watch the following video
on my channel.